[Music]
all right we're back let's go out to
Cincinatti and talk to Jennifer what's
up
Jennifer oh hi hi there Dr John what's
up so my question is this hold on that
was that was a big
sigh tell me it's the holiday season and
you're about to ask a really complex
question without saying anything ah all
right let's do
it okay how do I approach the presence
of my uncle at family
gatherings there's a long history in our
family around my uncle um 20 years ago
my little brother who was about 10 at
the time reported that my uncle had
masturbated in front of him on a camping
trip my uncle told him not to tell uh
police got involved but my brother
turned out to be an unreliable witness
and so the case didn't really go
anywhere
um my cousin my uncle's son has
confronted his father and alleged that
he was molested by his father um but so
he's currently no contact with his dad
my uncle u my uncle denies all these
allegations seems very sad but you know
the loss of all the connection but my
dad is his older
brother still there yeah I'm here he's
still there okay I got his text my dad
is very loyal to his younger brother um
invites him to our family gatherings now
when he's got no plans
um so I I feel so much tension about
this I mean there's no legal convictions
and he's this human sitting across from
me at the table at Gatherings and my
cousin feels betrayed um that his father
is still welcomed at Gatherings despite
way he went through and my younger
brother um not to mention him he still
acts like nothing even
happened um should I like protest that
he's invited to these things should I
not hug him when he walks in the door am
I complicit in this by not saying
anything like how do I how do I approach
this what's my posture towards him in
this yeah what a mess um when I I think
I missed something your brother said he
just acts like nothing happened or your
uncle acts like nothing nothing happened
they both do everyone does oh okay um
well I think there's a clear reason why
people act like that cuz your brother
did something scary and terrifying and
told the truth and nothing happened
except in a way he got in trouble right
when you're 10 and you have to go meet
with cops and you have to do all these
things and they ultimately say you're
not
reliable
uhhuh um you get a message loud and
clear shut your mouth nobody cares what
you have to say yeah followed up by
somebody else his age reports
something again nothing
happens right right so everybody has a
very clear message that um uh nothing
happened right except I am from the old
school where there's smoke there's fire
and if two young boys that have a lot to
lose both Point their fingers in a very
similar way to
somebody
um it's very rare like the movies where
two pathologic a cousin and a brother
get together like hey let's take down
like that just doesn't h i mean anyway
I'm I'm of the old
school
that where there's smoke there's
fire do you have kids yeah no okay so
this is this is L you're the fun ant
okay so this is largely about
you yeah have you asked your cousin and
your brother their feelings their
thoughts their ideas on all of
this uh I know my cousin's thoughts and
feelings about it so your your cousin
just doesn't won't
come right he doesn't have any
interaction with his dad and he thinks
everyone is a huge hypocrite who acts
like everything's fine and now he
doesn't come to things because his dad
is sad thing right and his kids don't
come you know
sure if I'd been molested by somebody
I'm not gonna let my kids be around them
right right um so yeah let's let's play
this back let's say your uncle really
did do these things a there's more boys
out there who are now men that this
happened
to
and think how his son
feels to have the courage to come out
and say the hardest thing you could ever
say against your a person against your
dad and he lost his family over it not
the other way
around it's pretty terrible yeah I mean
wow and let's just conf I mean you
you've mentioned some pretty important
things about Humanity of course your
uncle's sad of course he is he lost
everything
but him being sad isn't why I'm going
to
um in any way compromise my values still
can do what I think is right so let me
ask you you this I can't give you this
answer what do you think is
right I mean I'm inclined to believe the
children who said that an
adults violated them violated their
innocence um I struggle with I didn't
invite him to my gathering my parents
invited him to theirs so sometimes our
parents do things that um you've heard
me say this a million times behavior is
a
language yes and so if you invite them
then you're telling me you don't want me
to come that's great happy holidays okay
I do think that's a conversation to have
with your dad it's a grown-up
conversation that would be highly
uncomfortable for you but you're an
adult you can do it say Hey Dad I
reached to the point where I can't be in
his presence
anymore okay and so if you choose to
invite him he's your brother I get it
there's no legal findings I know but
I've talked to our our I've talked to
your
son and you're choosing your brother
over your son you're allowed to do that
but I'm gonna spend holidays with him
and um this other man's
son and by the way I would be
stunned stunned if your dad didn't have
an inkling one way or the
other
he acts like he's pretty
confident um that his son just made up a
huge lie about his
brother
yeah in law enforcement so he swears up
and down he knows to tell when people
are lying of course they do you you
should you should read the data on that
and I'm I know they're not any better
than anybody else nope but they're
infinitely more confident than they are
way more confident that's right that's
right I'm sorry it's a
mess it's not fun
yeah
um I'll tell you what I would do I'll
tell you what I would
do if um I have little brother he's not
little he's a grown man but I have a
little brother and if he came forward
and said this about one of my
uncles when he was 10 this this thing
happened and then I had another cousin
come out and say this thing about his
dad that would be enough for me that I
would choose to be with my little
brother okay that's just me it's not a
right or wrong it's not up or down yes
people make up things I've been a part
of those investigations too I know that
yes they do and it's not very common
and not from multiple sources and not
when people have get investigated yeah
people don't get investigated multiple
times over different years for the same
thing and still be
innocent uh I mean maybe but it's just
it's a that's why he's not in jail
because maybe right yeah
um what does your gut tell
you my gut tells me that my that the kid
stole the truth okay fell your
gut and Jennifer I know what that means
that means hell I
know yeah and I'm I don't like to make
trouble I know Trouble made
you and if your uncle actually did these
things um he's the one who chose to burn
down your family tree not you you're
trying to replant it in fertile
soil yes fertile soil
yes okay all right and this is all
different because there's a potential
child molester in the mix there's is all
different because there's no repentance
there was no I screwed up there's no
redemp I mean there's nothing to be
redeemed here it's it's it's a adults
versus multiple kids and the adult one
now maybe when you meet with your dad
your dad could say hey I'm going to show
you some evidence that you didn't know
existed when you were
younger um those boys got together and
made this whole thing up
check everybody
okay yeah no the dog sees the mailman
okay cool um so may maybe that's the
case I I'm think there's a
0.00000000 1% chance that's that's the
case
sounds more
like um your dad doesn't want to believe
this and can't believe this about his
brother and so he chose his brother over
his son and thought ah he's just a kid
he'll get over it by the way parents if
your kids come to you with this sort of
hey this happened to me when it comes to
sexual abuse always default to believing
your children first
always
always that sounds really not like them
start with I believe
you always Jennifer I'm sorry not by
your hand but in your lap this mess came
upon you
and conversations I would start my
little
brother and maybe you have to start and
say I'm sorry I believed you but I've
just kept showing up because I don't
like to make trouble and Jennifer got a
pair of boxing gloves for Christmas and
so I'm going to make some trouble by the
way everybody listening to this this
call is coming before the holidays and
I'm imagining Jennifer's entering into
the holiday season and you'll be hearing
this after some of these hard
conversations so Jennifer feel free to
call us back and let us know how those
conversations
went